[Music]
foreign
look at what's on the front pages as
they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the columnist
Carol Malone and the editor of The
Courier in Dundee David cleck they'll be
with us from now right up until just
before midnight so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
the guardian reports that four
conservative ministers have called on
Rishi sunak to break the deadlock in the
dispute with the Royal College of
Nursing by entering negotiations over
paid
the Metro Pictures nurses on a picket
line in Liverpool who despite being on
strike went to the aid of a man who'd
collapsed nearby
the express also leads with nurses
telling Britain to sit down and sort
this out
the eye hears that 999 services in all
10 of England's ambulance trusts are
being placed under extreme pressure that
they're facing an operational crisis
the telegraph says the NHS is on high
alert as Hospital admissions for the flu
have jumped more than 40 percent in a
week
the financial times has word of the bank
of England and the European Central
bank's decision to raise their
respective interest rates by half a
percentage point
David's paper The Courier speaks to a
pharmacist in Fife who describes the
demand for strep a antibiotics as chaos
the star accuses Prince Harry of
insisting he wants privacy whilst also
divulging contentious exchanges with his
father and brother in the latest chapter
of his Netflix docu-series
indeed the male describes the prince and
princess of Walter's appearance at a
Carol concert tonight as dignity in the
face of treachery
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Carol
Malone and David Clegg welcome to you
both let's start with the star not
something we we do very often but we
will tonight dad told Whoppers and my
scary brother screamed at me uh direct
quotes from a Prince Harry in their
latest installation of his Netflix
docu-series uh what do you make of that
Carol
well they sound like a couple of kids
you know it's true there was you know
the stuff I had to kind of the reason
I'm so tired now is I had to go to the
crack at all today to watch these two in
the latest three hours of you know
whining and moaning and woe as me and
this one was actually kind of worse in
that sense than last week but then they
came out
saying that the rest of the Royals were
jealous of them which is why they were
edged out of the right family which is
absolutely Tosh I mean they've got a
very inflated idea of their own
popularity Harry was saying that Megan
was stealing the Limelight which is why
some of the senior Royals turned against
her and will say Harry stained Wheels
bullied me like a kid this is a guy who
fought in Afghanistan for goodness sake
and he's saying his brother losing his
temper with him in a meeting terrified
him I mean he they well Harry
particularly sounds like a kid it's and
today it's suddenly because he has now
totally ended any chance of a
relationship ever again with his brother
Wills will never talk to him again after
this he has he has
berated him yet again in the eyes of the
world he's called his father a liar in
the eyes of the world and and you know
the the headline on the mail today is
saying that you know dignity in the face
of treachery when the royal family went
to the annual Carroll service at
Westminster Abbey and yes they are very
dignified but I'm not sure that they
shouldn't say something now I think they
should they can't keep on taking hits
like that and not respond I know they're
probably thinking because the American
Press are now turning against them
they're the the American requests are
now questioning what they say because
everything they say Jillian is entirely
uncorroborated everything how he said
about William about the screaming mat in
this meeting it's on corroborated
there's no proof
I'm just going to say let's um let's
bring David in because I'm interested in
that point that Carol raises that she
believes the royal family should now
speak up are you of that view as well
should they respond
I I think the dignified silence actually
has worked for them so far I unlike
Carol I got up at the normal time this
morning so I haven't I haven't seen uh
the latest episodes yet but um it's it
seems that while I think it's very
unedifying that it's a deeply sad
spectacle uh and that uh Harry and
Megan's decision to uh promote it this
way and to attack their the family so
publicly is is regrettable I I don't
think there's been anything uh there's
been no real explosive bombshell there
it feels like it feels like it it hasn't
been as dramatic or as damaging as the
palace perhaps feared or suspected it
would be so I think the fact that they
have maintained the dignified silence
throughout it has actually worked quite
well in their favor and I'm not sure
there's anything in particular that's
came to light that they need to respond
to it's not like an accusation of a
particular incident of racism or some of
the other things we've heard in the past
I don't think there was anything at
quite that category so I think I think
that the star actually uh which we
started with there uh some sums it up
pretty well because I I think that kind
of mocking attitude towards it is
actually the best way to go about it it
is quite clear and Prince Harry makes uh
no secret of the fact that he loves the
British press uh but I think looking
across the front pages of tomorrow's
papers it's quite clear that the Phil is
mutual yeah uh just very quickly cows I
want to move on but the the Whoppers
that the star alludes to was there any
detail what these alleged lies were
well I mean basically saying that that
you know that the royal family planted
stories about them in the press one of
course was the president Megan and Harry
did that can I say one thing I think
this is the one that guy I looked at her
today and and I thought what a
squandered wasted opportunity she 'd
been fantastic for the royal family it
did need an injection of life it did
need an injection a modern day
perspective she could have provided that
and in the first six months she
absolutely did and then it was
squandered on the altar of of their own
vanity and I just think that is such a
waste it's such a missed opportunity
meanwhile the male
um they think that uh Prince William and
uh Kate the the princess and prince of
Wales that uh they're dignified in the
face of what they're describing as as
treachery is that a word that you might
use to describe it David
I think treachery is a good tabloid bird
it feels it feels a bit strong certainly
I think given that this is uh is brawler
that we're talking about I think Carol
might disagree but anyway
given it as his brother that they're
talking about here it starts I think
it's certainly it's certain it certainly
doesn't it isn't something that is
comfortable to witness really it's it's
deep it's a deeply uncomfortable
spectacle I think I'm not sure if if I
would take it to the level of treachery
though
when you slayed your own father and your
own brother you call your dad a liar you
call your whole family racist you don't
think that's treacherous my God what
would he have to do for it to me
worse goes on in ordinary families
um and and they managed to patch things
up
no that's the only difference that's the
only difference but they're no different
to any other family to be honest let's
have a look at the Garden we'll move on
to to politics now
um and the nurses strike that that took
place today the historic strike that
took place first time in the in their
history
especially soon like the prime minister
is being urged to just basically sit
down and sort this out
yes and I think I think from a Scottish
perspective it's quite interesting
actually because this strike's not
happening in Scotland because the
Scottish government did sit down with
the Royal College of nurses and they've
came to an agreement uh which I think
was about an average of 7.5 pay rise
what the guardian is reporting tomorrow
and what we're we're seeing uh and some
of the other papers as well is I think
actually Rishi sunak is under a lot of
pressure here I think particularly
because it's nurses you notice even the
express which uh is a is a paper that
you would imagine would be hostile
towards strikes and Strikers that that
is pretty supportive of the nurses
really as far as a Daily Express front
page goes and what what they're saying
uh what the guardian is saying is that
there's there's concern from amongst the
conservative party about how this is
playing out publicly and they're asking
the prime minister to you know take it
into his personal entry and get to grips
with it they continue to uh uh say that
this has been uh the pay review board
has made I've made this decision looked
about it and that their hands are tired
on that it feels like the tide is moving
on that and it's not really a position
that's going to be sustainable in the
long term especially if we do have this
winter crisis in the NHS everyone is
very stretched I think there's a great
deal of sympathy for nurses they're not
well paid and I think this is a strike
that the government would be very keen
to resolve if they could well the Royal
College of Nursing is threatened to
Stage strikes for months to come if
ministers don't start to negotiate a
better deal but but as you say that
sympathy does appear to be there for the
nurses and when you look at the story on
the front of the Metro with nurses
abandoning their placards to help
somebody who was in distress who who
collapsed ill in Bristol
um it shows that they really are in
their profession to help people
I mean Julian I would expect anyone to
go to the aid of someone who collapsed
in the street it wouldn't have to be a
nurse it would be anyone I don't think
that's their Heroes for that but I mean
I think their demand for 19 it's crazy
it's never going to happen the country
can't afford that and you just said
there that that they're poorly paid the
average salary for under 32 Grand plus
increments plus pensions plus waiting
allowances in London it and and for an
experiences 50 odd grad this is great
but it's not bad so and and I think you
know we we keep on we keep on talking
about this is yes they do a fantastic
job and
a pandemic than being here as in the
pandemic the pandemics throw up lots of
Heroes Supermarket workers Dustbin
workers people who went to work every
single day and will get paid a lot less
than 32 Grand a year so I think I think
arubicon was crossed today I I don't
think I think it's bad that people in
the emergency services people whose jobs
it is to save lives are going on strike
not only are they going on strike
they're threatening this for months to
come the right College of Nursing today
refused to guarantee Cancer Care so this
is this is a shocking State of Affairs
and that's not just going to be for one
day because they're saying this could be
for months to come let's not forget the
nurses have had a 4.5 paywriter they
were given what the pay review body said
they should have yes so just just to end
up just to end on on that point uh
former head of the prb Jerry cope he
said the body should consider revisiting
its original finding as it may be a
possibility for a solution for this in
apparently in track problem
that things have changed in fact it's
being fixed in Scotland suggests it's
not intractable it just requires the
political will to fix it welcome back
you're watching the Press previews tour
with me Cara Malone and David cleck let
us have a look at the uh Telegraph
um and this worrying story is if the the
NHS hasn't got enough to to worry about
um Hospital admissions have jumped 40 in
a week for uh flu there is an outbreak
which could be the worst in years David
yes it is it's a it's a it's quite a
concerning story on the front page it's
uh uh as as they think it could pass the
peak of the 2017-2018 night brick which
is one of the worst flu years of the
past 20 years during which nearly 30 000
people died and they say flu cases are
so high they have now overtaken covert
admissions for the first time since the
start of the pandemic so I think given
the context of what I've been talking
about with the nurses strike there is a
great deal of pressure on the Health
Care system in general at the minute we
know that we still haven't recovered
from the the Damage Done during the
covert pandemic and that backlog we've
seen uh situations in Scotland with some
of the worst waiting times on record and
there's that pressure across the UK so a
serious flu crisis like that feels like
it could be a very serious serious
problem in the weeks ahead so I think
people will be watching that very
carefully and and with a certain sense
of forebuilding actually indeed um to
your paper David The Courier but we'll
get to Carol to kick off and this is a
pharmacist in fine life describing it as
chaos the the lack of antibiotics to
treat strep a
I'm not really the one to talk about
whether
it's what I don't understand is how we
can have a shortage of antibiotics in
this country these are basic drugs how
can we have a shortage of something that
is so should be so easy to get held off
and can cure strep a very quickly kids
are dying with this and all they need is
a very simple antibiotic why isn't it
then David jump in with 30 seconds
yeah I mean this I I just think it's a
very brief pharmacist she saw her she
should not go on the television saying
there was no shortage and and she has
put her head above the parapet and told
us there's no penicillin the second
antibiotic you would normally take at
that stage would be amoxicillin we've
got no amoxicillinyler the case numbers
are are very high in Scotland there's a
great deal of concern and I think the
phone calls from frantic parents were
ringing around pharmacies trying to find
penicillin for their sick child it's a
it's a nightmare situation and just
leads to that sense that uh the Health
Service is creaking at the moment